Committee in the department and Dr
Leslie King was recruited by one of our
faculty Dr Paul Gorman who is
unfortunately out on medical leave he's
doing fine he's doing well but uh he's
not able to make it and um I some of you
have seen the materials about Dr King
that Lynn sent around and it's very
interesting I'm looking forward to
hearing her story but I won't give my my
usual long-winded introduction I'll be
really brief she's a physician she went
to medical school at University of
Virginia she trained in emergency
medicine she also has an mph degree from
Johns Hopkins University and she's done
so much that if I actually told the
whole story I would give her a whole
talk so I'm going to let her give her
talk and she will give her a
presentation then I assume we'll have
time for questions yes yes thank you
thank you for having me I am moving into
screen here just give me a minute we've
yeah we're getting there with our
okay so um there's only uh three of us
well Dr King and three others of us in
the room here but there's 23 others
assigned so you have a nice
audience to listen
hello all can you I know that the folks
in the room here can see me can you guys
see me okay out there in the world or am
I just a voice talking yeah
okay okay well nice to meet you all
welcome to the folks that are here as Dr
said my name's Leslie king
um I'm originally from Virginia
um but I've been in Oregon I actually
came for a job post-residency so I've
been here since 97. so I've been here 25
years now
um the last 12 or so I spent overseas
again I went away for a job for a year I
ended up staying for a dozen so I was in
New Zealand and Australia for the past
12 years and kind of got stuck there
when everyone got stuck due to coven so
just getting back now
um I came across Paul Gorman in my other
role so uh one of the many ways I
transitioned back was to kind of flip
more into my medical writing
um back during those Oregon days back 20
years ago I wrote op-eds and things were
published
um they went absolutely nowhere
um a few people wrote back and you know
it got some uptake but not a lot
um and at the time I was writing about
things like the impact of climate change
on human health things of that nature
um that suddenly have traction now but
then no one was knowing what any of that
meant
um so I Revisited it you know during the
the whole lockdown and you know we were
all thinking of interesting ways to
spend our time locked indoors I kind of
went back to my writing but I kind of
flipped into what I call mixed modality
and started working with an illustrator
and you know thinking about taking
advantage of the internet
um and links and photography and music
and you know making it multi-modal and
multi-disciplinary if you will just
engaging more than one part of your
brain so that what you'll see today is
the out growth of that
and also when I was getting locked up
and we were you know thinking about
other skill sets and what else can we do
you know how can we use the time I was
approached by some folks at the Oregon
Fish and Wildlife Department and I went
through the ranks and eventually I was
appointed by Governor Kate Brown as a
commissioner for the Oregon Department
of Wildlife so that's actually how I
came across Dr Paul Gorman he listened
to my podcast
um which is on the beaver State podcast
which is some of the links that I've
sent you guys so if you listen to that
um it was time for black history month
so we talked about a variety of things
like working in Rural Oregon we talked
about Dei we talked about a number of
things and and
when Paul contacted me
I said hey by the way I have this comic
as well and we got to talking and that
ended up with me meeting with you today
so nice to meet you again we'll get
cracking with what I have called it's
it's officially a mini comic I think
because it's so short but what I have
called
um and it grew out of my bed my comic
and Dr visible the origin story so
actually I'm hitting the down button
nothing seems to be do I have to hit
something else
there it goes okay all right so this is
me senoir so as I explained straight out
of Virginia like Missy Elliott okay on a
three times black eye then so many
people like what's a black Ivy so if you
go to an Ivy League obviously obviously
your leader so you're an ivy
um if you're black you're a black Ivy of
the ancient eight I've attended three
hence three times black Ivy okay I have
lived and worked on all six inhabited
continents
um Australia and austral Asia being the
last where I just came back from
I'm certified qualified pedigreed
published fellowed and appointed and I
am definitely not hiding in plain sight
yet for some reason I haven't been seen
until now like suddenly I'm I'm The It
Girl
and it just is very much it's very much
reminiscent of you know op-eds I wrote
20 years ago that suddenly are being
seen for the first time
so that got me to thinking
sorry it's a little bit touchy uh that
got me to thinking about
what this all means and I wrote an op-ed
which is what I always do
and the
opening line of the op-ed is I am
suddenly visible
and
that's where I kind of explored like why
like you know I haven't changed the
intonation of my voice haven't changed
in height weight in a long long time
um you know like nothing about me is
particularly different I'm older maybe
I'm Wiser but like suddenly I I'm I'm
within View and suddenly I'm in demand
and and it it was one of these you know
it's a head-inning thing like with the
world around you changes and it's sort
of like you're used to just sort of
always being ignored ridiculed you know
pushed aside like treated like you know
some hippie doctor that works out there
in the field what do you know
to suddenly being in demand and Dean's
calling you and wanting to come to
present at a journal Club it's just kind
of it's just sort of a dizzying
experience so I've studied you know
we've got to take advantage of that
we've got to see what that means and and
explore what that means as a society a
culture a world and I learned from a
friend of mine she's something I don't
understand it's something like
neuropsych cognitive development
learning how people learn kind of person
to do something failing oh you is that
better okay
oh dear
I see
you can move my laptop sorry we're still
having a little bit of oh there okay
that's better yeah better wait the um
the the video in the all is the one
that's going on now but this should be
oh instead of the one in front of me
sorry yeah I see your slides okay okay
well you don't need to see me unless you
just want to see my French blue
um
so the the friend of mine that I don't
understand but she actually helped me
quite a lot and
um she described the four learning types
and the four learning types I think are
directly related to essentially they
could be the four communication types
but
these three if you think about
when you're
two years old
you see something you grab it and then
pretty quickly somebody tells you no and
then you say no in this whole big fight
and it's just the this Loop right here
it's not until
you're five or six and somebody ships
you off to kindy or wherever and you get
your book learning and you learn your
reading and your writing
and then suddenly
that one takes
precedence that one is given all of the
Credence that one is also important and
we forget about these other three
and I think when when I when my friend
was explaining to me about the learning
types and that I the reason I made it
red is I'm particularly a visual learner
it just I had that aha moment and that
that is why my communication isn't
working it's because I'm here in the
reading and writing to death
what this happened before now it's an
alarm
um there's an alarm right outside sorry
it yeah it's literally if you're
standing Too Close it'll go off it's the
alarm for like I guess people stealing
the equipment the auto equipment over
there so um I learned that the hard way
so what I realized when I was doing my
op-eds is this one the reading and the
writing and I was selling myself short I
was only one quarter and what if I
started combining some of these other
ones like visual like auditory like what
I described like putting music or
pictures accompanying the words I would
have a much bigger head and that's
exactly what has begun to happen and so
I would just say like this is true in
every type of learning it's true in
medicine I I remember
I remember Harrison's quite vividly I
think we all do I never read it ever
which is probably to the Chagrin of most
of medical people but what I did is I
made my own tables I made my own
pictures I I was doing essentially what
I'm doing with my comic because I cannot
just sit there and read 10 point text I
just can't do it it does not go into my
head
so that's one of the things that I you
know I just sort of in speaking to her
who's essentially learns how people
learn and tries to help them it actually
ended up helping me a great great deal
and it helped my communication I think a
great great deal
so this is just an example
of how I learn and how I see the world
and when I was presenting this as a as a
project this was started as a project
for a Harvard media and Medicine writing
project
and of course they didn't know what I
was talking about they're like why
aren't you just writing about that like
what are you doing that's the kind of
thing and what I sent them was this I
just made this on you know what do you
call it the the hyper text or hybrid
it's the little thing like within
PowerPoint where you can make the little
models and you know the little um
a higher graphic hierarchy charts that's
what I did I just picked one that had
circles and what I just demonstrated is
covid is taking all the oxygen out of
the room
that's all we're talking about you know
by the way there was a malaria vaccine
by the way
um you know that's one of the biggest
scourges of mankind of all of mankind
wait wait wait bigger than covet
you know and
we now have a vaccine that should be
front page news but that's not what
we're talking about kitties
the captain out of school which means
their immunizations are late so all the
other viruses are going to Surge
who knows what was happening to him at
home he forgot all about the safety net
that schools
you know that we've forgotten all about
the educational drop-off they've had you
know what about kids that are food
insecure what about that don't have heat
at home you know all of these things
that we're missing because all we're
talking about is this one thing and just
today
I was reading about this I remember so I
guess it was 21.
when it was 90 000 people died of opioid
overdoses we're now well over 100 and to
give that scale
you know people were up in arms about
Vietnam the Vietnam conflict lasted for
11 years
58 000 people died
well modern day if you take gunshots
and car crashes and combine those two
they surpass Vietnam every single year
so every January 1st we have a new
Vietnam
right opioid overdoses dwarfs both of
those and they are increasing
and again all we're talking about is
this that's taken all the action out of
the room and so that again to me it's
what impacted me is the visual like
seeing those graphs and seeing those
charts and seeing what we're missing
that is sort of like you know I had that
aha moment like tell the story in
another way
it's it's kind of essentially what I'm
getting around saying
so this again and and I had to explain
this to the Harvard people because again
they were just like well just write an
op-ed which I did I actually did write
an op-ed that I showed you and I use
that op-ed as the original story from
Iconic so I did actually do that so you
know he had to write an op-ed a press
release
and some other like brand
sort of bland boring regular everyday
thing
that you would expect from a media and
Medicine writing program very straight
and narrow that's how we tend to do
things in medicine right that's how we
tend to to force people to learn
and so I did that but then I took it
next step and I took my op-ed
and made it more of an OP duck which is
a very
most opdocs you know you have to be
there at times or something because it
requires like a video team you need a
whole cinematographer you know I mean
it's they're really elaborate and
they're you know sometimes up to 10 and
20 minute videos that accompany an op-ed
and tell kind of a thread of the story
that's within the op-ed it's a really
cool way of Storytelling you just have
to be the New York Times to pull it off
um I got more into to not just novels
but graphic novels like looking at for
example the most brilliant thing I've
seen recently is James choices Ulysses
that has been reimagined as a graphic
novel
that's probably the first time I ever
even thought about looking at a reading
Ulysses it's incredible and it was
really well done and it's just again
because it engages I think different
parts and more more parts of your brain
and that's when I started getting
storytelling and visual storytelling
again using this mixed modality and so
my big inspiration I think a lot of
people's big inspiration you know if you
look at narrative medicine and graphic
medicine and that kind of burgeoning
field pretty much everyone in that field
will tell you that they were somehow
impacted by Mouse
now Mouse has gotten a lot of hype here
recently because it was banned and now
you can't find it because it's flying
off the shelves because people who know
it was and now they're running to get it
and
this is probably the best Holocaust
story ever told it is incredible and it
is pictures of mice and cats that's
essentially what it is
and with device and cats it tells this
amazing story you cannot put it down
when you pick it up and the just
I think anyone who's ever seen it a kind
of is it you go away changed and you you
just think what have I been doing this
whole time you know it kind of and this
was before there was a thing called a
graphic novel Mouse basically created it
because when it won the Pulitzer it won
it in a special category they didn't
know what the hell to even call it they
just kind of like you just win you know
we'll just give you a special category
and you know now we have a thing called
a graphic novel we take it all for
granted it is because of this book
um and of course it's been Revisited
ends now there's now metamouse there's
all the different volumes there's
different sizes it's been banned now you
can't find it but I think this was the
groundbreaking novel from there there
was persepolis the most recent really
amazing example I can think of is March
which John Lewis has reimagined his
entire story
um on the Edmond Pettis bridge and all
of that as a graphic novel again akin to
Mouse is a three-part
um in a slip case volume incredible
stuff and and of course there's the
written all the things that we know
about John Lewis but reimagining as that
graphic novel it tells the story I think
anew
so that's kind of what I hope to do
and what I also hope to do is is again
thinking about the types of learning and
and all the ways that we learn
you know the original Matrix was
groundbreaking and amazing of course the
prequel the sequel the reboot all
everything since then was just
absolutely stupid but if you if you
remember the original Matrix
and the remember there is no spoon
moment
to me that says it all is that we create
the constructs of our own reality
we decide the norms you know you think
about currency what gives currency any
worth we decided you know each country
makes their own you know at the end of
the day when you look at it it really is
a piece of freaking paper with you know
fancy drawing on it but we decide what
gives it worse and that to me is what
always resonates from the scene to me is
remembering there is no spoon is that if
we create it we can uncreate it like
we're the ones who decide uh well that's
like a silly child form of communication
why you know I mean so I think that's
kind of remember what I was kind of
going through as I was trying to create
this comic and just remembering there is
no spoon is the whole free your mind and
if you remember if you saw the Matrix
and the character of Neo once he did
free his mind and remember there was no
spoon he could quote fly and that's
exactly it isn't it we create our own
limitations so again we cannot create
them
and this one is just you know I've
worked a lot with Native people all over
the world
and this one you know he's not winking
this isn't like some American cutesy
cutesy this is on purpose the Inuit
Storyteller meaning the people of the
Arctic Circle
with one one looking behind forward and
back one looking within and without and
again that is so key to all storytelling
and remembering there is no spoon
that you know when I saw this a friend
of mine who knew what I was doing sent
me this I I just I remember staring at
it for a really long time I was going to
use this for something
um but I think it speaks to
what I'm trying to create
with Dr invisible
and so now you know the story of how I
created it um hopefully you saw
the PDFs
um I for the folks here
um I actually made a booklet
so and again it's officially it's a mini
comment because it's so short but
essentially if you imagine just 11 by 17
folded in half with some Staples down
that's what it looks like in in real
form as opposed to just the PDF and
again you have to you're always messing
with
what modality you're in because when
it's online it Scrolls whereas obviously
when you read it in English it goes left
to right so you have to always kind of
be conscious of what you're actually
looking at to make it make sense because
there's a huge genre I just learned of
today manga they're Japanese Comics that
are translated and of course because
it's Japanese you have to read them the
opposite way and it's just it's just
this whole completely mind-bending thing
so I mean I think that again I think
it's important because it forces you to
use other other parts of your brain
so without further ado
this is the comic now this is this
breaks a lot of rules Comics again this
is my first stab at it
um many of the Portland because Portland
State and
Portland Community College they actually
both have Departments of comics and
that's how I found some of my
illustrators and one of the guy who's a
professor of comics just looks at he was
just kind of appalled and you know but I
said these are two people I said you got
to remember not every one of us no think
about comics and we made a comic so you
know give us a break here but officially
a comic is five panels
30 words or less per page so the point
is you're telling a story with the
pictures now if you look at many many
Comics if you if you ever look at mouse
or percentage they broke the broke the
rules as well
um and so much of it is like originally
they were big they were tabloid size so
like there's many more per page so when
you shrink it it looks all funny that
sort of thing you always have to keep in
mind like what you're looking at so
essentially because I knew you guys were
looking at it as a PowerPoint what I did
is I made the whole spread so this is a
two-page spread so you start here again
and I always say remember the Z in
English so you start top left
across like the Z then down and then
across and depending on how many panels
you have like for example Mouse it'll
have two or three of those where you're
constantly like think of like the
old-fashioned typewriter we're
constantly hitting the river the return
and you don't have to do it the thing
about pictures is that you don't have to
do it quite that way because you can
flit about because so many people I knew
flitted right to here you know so I mean
and then they went back and went you're
dead and then they went back and read
the next you know and so it it's it is
about what you see and how you see it
and of course that is determined by your
perspective
um and
the the order doesn't matter because you
can always go back and regroup so this
is again you start hearing go around
here then and then the same thing with
this and
this is page two
um it's the spread if if you're looking
at it like um in a PowerPoint or here
live and on the paper and again as you
go across and then you come down through
the inset that was done on purpose the
inset and then like where I died my
glasses come off and I'm like rolling
around looking house and again across
and then down and across so that's how
all Comics work and the key to Comics
also I think what makes them an amazing
medium is all the stuff you can put in
it
um the things on the wall the things of
the text
the clothing that they're wearing
the calendars you know all that sort of
things it's the story behind the story
so many people have told me that they've
read it three times and each time they
saw something else which that is the
point like that's hopefully the intent
of a comic and officially this is what's
called an explainer comic which is kind
of a rising genre of taking complex
topics and using again more than one
modality to get to the to get to the
story so this again doesn't have quite
the effect when you're looking at it on
a PowerPoint but when you're flipping
through the pages you go from black and
white to color so kind of a Wizard of Oz
style is what I was kind of trying to
create with that
um
and again the same thing you started
right
sorry top left and you go across with
the Z and again all the different things
that are here and buried like things on
the bookshelf
um quotations
Etc who's on the podium that all these
things like I tried to kind of bring all
of those things to life
um and you can do so much like for
example you you have to still write a
comic so for for all the people that
were really appalled like well you're
right and you write so well
um I'm like but I'm still writing like
you have to write a comic and then the
the illustrator can then combine and you
literally it's a fancy horse trade like
the the writer and the illustrator have
to work together they have you have to
be in sync and they have to understand
what you're trying to convey and then
draw it properly and a lot of times you
know like they were able to combine
several scenes like in text they could
do it like quickly in a picture
and again I think that speaks to the
combining the modalities and I think
ideally
one of the things like this is you start
here and then you go and read the op-ed
or you go and read an article or a text
or you you go in and go further this is
a in many ways an entry point it's a way
to get you thinking and talking
and then this
if you see the top major look did you
see because I'm still playing on the
invisible part in that
all throughout the comics there are
Easter eggs like Cohen style Easter eggs
um and the question is how many of them
did you pick up and I remember when I
first showed this to Dr Gorman he was
just looking at me and said you're going
to have to explain this to me
conversations
you know did you know that
Blues boy Riley
is was from Indianola and what
Mississippi homecom represented
Etc you know did you see you know all
the Naz disorganil Hurston
um the clotilda and Cujo Lewis and all
those things there's so much
medical and black history there's so
much in there that again many people
like I said every time they read it they
saw something else and that was the
point and that was the goal and online
for example if I go back
for example
like when I fall out of the truck like a
tournament like I actually moved it's
there's it's a little emotional thud
sound kind of thing
um
the Buffalo the Buffalo Soldier rears
back the the
I guess Mist fog you know condensation
from the T moves my my arm moves I'm
brushing my teeth all of these links
like weathering effect
there's links to that and what it means
and and I've specifically an imposter
syndrome and specifically those are
there because how they affect black and
brown and female
professionals or not just professionals
but all of us frankly like what that
means exactly
so moving on
speaking of weather effect
this is a man that
we should just never say his name ever
ever again the University of South
Carolina where he was from and the
medical school was named for him has
taken his name down
the uh College I was sessions and
Gynecology they're Williams obstetrics
has a huge forward that explains who
this guy is and yes he created the
speculum but we're not calling it The
Sims speculum ever again and why and why
I'm not sure this is going to work
if we're going to say somebody's name
say Lucy's an arches or betsies
because talk about weathering effect
talking about like having systemic
racism shorten your life
these girls were teenagers all of them
14 15 16 years old
and this guy experimented on them doing
pelvic surgeries I think an Archer alone
he did 30 surgeries without anesthesia
it's crazy I mean like you know people
being apoplectic you know and we built
monuments to this guy
and that's in our medical textbooks and
that's what somebody like me who looks
like me who that that Lucy could have
been Leslie has to come and read
it's like are you flipping kidding me
get that out of the medical text like
that's not okay and you you can't just
say well look at all the things in the
fistula surgeries he did and how it
benefited women over time
all he was doing was experimenting on
black women and using it to enrich
himself on white women and he documented
it quite well
actually
I mean his so that's the sort of thing
when I talk about weathering effect and
imposter syndrome that's some of the
things that your black and brown
colleagues or any other colleague of
oppressed people are facing
um all those little microaggressions and
how they add up
you know I know the thing that I put
you're too young to be a doctor yeah
this lady her name you need to say we
say Hilo all the time
all the time the immortal sound like
she like me is straight out of Virginia
by the time she died she made it to
Johns Hopkins mother of five she died of
cervical cancer and like her mid-30s or
so
without her knowledge about anybody's
knowledge
they took tissue from her
and from her they created what is now
considered the immortal cell line every
kind of surge every kind of research you
can imagine across all the medical
spectrum is based on the Gila strain
without consent without knowledge her
family is still suffering from all of
the racial inequities that we talk about
with black lives matter they're still
just as broke they live in neighborhoods
that are just as redlined they never got
any of the benefit of all of that
surgery
don't even bother to say her name
so I do
her name was Henrietta Lacks
name her strain say her name
don't just gloss that over
and not understand like what people went
through
this this is not subtle you know people
think that you know this is a
microaggression this is an affront to
people this is deeply insulting
and people do it every day like we just
said he was trying like you know you
shrug shoulders like
okay
this is where I talk about stop saying
slave state
and Free State in Oregon getting off the
hook that you know oh well we never had
slavery here
you can't get much more north than Rhode
Island and I picked Rhode Island for a
reason because of the three black ivies
I went to one was Brown
and one of the things every single black
student always said is I do not want a
diploma
that says plantations
on it
all of the Brown family
benefited from slavery all of Rhode
Island did because they had more slaves
we have than any other state in New
England
because they were the one of the points
of the triangle trade with a slave for
two sugar and molasses from the
Caribbean the Molasses were brought to
Providence to make the rum
was shipped to West Africa
the ships came back with more slaves to
Providence that triangle went on for
hundreds of years where I went to school
there was a poll outside of the English
Department where the slaves were chained
when you went to the the off student
houses Benefit Street this halfway down
College Hill
all the houses had hatches in the
basement
where they snuck up the slaves from the
harbor
that is why we need to stop saying Slave
versus free this is a slave country
it was built on rape and theft and
slavery just like every other Empire in
the history of the world they're all the
same we could be talking about the
Mongol Empire the British one the Roman
they're all the same call it what it is
and stop trying to gloss over and say
well that's not us
so instead of talking about a far away
State let's talk about this one 33rd
State she flies with her own Wings right
well
1844. first of three black exclusion
laws when Oregon was still territory
all right by the time we got to 1857 the
third one passed and it was actually
adopted into Constitution at the time of
statehood in 1859.
so no you didn't have slaves here but
you effectively excluded everybody out
like Oregon is a white state for a
reason it's on purpose it's on design
it's not an accident
there were laws
specifically
sundowning laws like if you look at
where black people live in Portland they
live north right at the edge of the
river
because at night they had to go home
usually they had to ship across to
Washington come back again so because of
these exclusion laws they were then
pinned into neighborhoods
that were then redlined
therefore they didn't get their
intergenerational wealth they were never
able to own their homes their businesses
you know I say this all the time because
I I just went to breakfast this morning
and I gave a tip to the lovely lady she
brought me my sandwich and every time I
cringe
because tipping
is a remnant of slavery
every every time everywhere we go
there's evidence of remiss of slavery
and the reason I know that the Tipping
is because reconstruction when all the
slaves are free
they won't have to work they left the
plantation went off to work those people
didn't pay them
they had to do their little step
infection routine so the customers would
give them a tip and that's how they made
the money
so
every time you give a tip
to someone who is underpaid
that is a remnant of slavery it is
throughout our entire Society no one is
immune no State can say we're not a
slave state that isn't a word [ __ ]
okay like we need to own it we need to
call it what it is and get it out there
and talk about it instead of this this
constant spinning about like you know
like we we don't have blame or guilt
like we didn't do that like why is that
on us
kind of thing
and this I put this in this is a
Portland State yeah
and
this kind of I've been working with
Portland State and some of the groups
within Portland trying to get like
people of color Outdoors
and this describes one of the barriers
so what Portland State did they found
out where all the emitters were
and they overlaid where all the black
people are and lo and behold
the Deep Purple is where the black
people are and they made a little
graphic of where all the emitters are
and again this is the Columbia this is
right across from where they had to go
in terms of the sundowning laws right so
they were forced
into the course neighborhoods into the
poorest you know settings places where
they had the emitters
no trees look at where all the trees are
here's the Willamette look at all the
trees look at Forest Park
I don't see any trees on this side
this is by Design
it is not by accident
and so one of the things that we are
facing again this puts in my hat with
ODFW is we can't just talk about getting
people outside we've really got to talk
about environmental justice like why are
people afraid to go outside like you
know if you live here the outside might
mean your Cosmos sets off
you know um the outside isn't safe
and again this kind of gets into my
Lewis and Clark bit you know we say
I should say sorry ODFW Ben we say Lewis
and Clark at the reading Virginia
gentleman Missouri one connect the dots
and then you instantly trespass because
what the Louisiana Purchase bought was
everything east of the Mississippi
they promptly went up River West of
Mississippi so classic
five finger discount
you know class may call it Manifest
Destiny theft
of the whole of the place
when you bought it
okay
can we also say your way
and I'm not even sure if we're saying
that right sacajawei it's definitely not
Sacagawea
that much a no
York was Clark's safe
he went there and back again as a slave
all he asked was his freedom
Clark just sold into his brother said
I'll get rid of him shoot him I don't
care
and so where York asked to go was
Kentucky where his enslaved family was
and so his statue is actually in
Louisville Kentucky
away was Shoshone
and not only did she make sure a whole
bunch of white boys end up as fish food
she
was pregnant
had a baby and a toddler this was a
two-year Journey
out there in the wilderness with a kid
and we don't even say her name right
there is at least some justice because
she was Shoshone and by all counts most
historical accounts I should say the
Oregon name state name in like over half
a state names are derived from Native
American languages
and the Shoshone phrase aguapion
means River the West so most likely
it was named
because of her and her people in the
Shoshone so at least there's that
but that's all and her statue actually
is
Lewiston Idaho of all places it's
something like that but again this is
all part of the National Park Service
because they're doing a lot to bring
other stories into outdoors and public
spaces so that gets a little bit into my
role with ODFW commissioner and I think
this is the end I put this at the end of
the
paper version I just sort of did a CV as
a map
and it was because it was booklet style
and we had to I think we had 10 pages
you had to do 12. so we needed another
fold out and so I did a map
um and this gets to a little bit if
people I have the discussion about rural
medicine and some of the places I worked
um like particularly my most recent was
rural flying doctors so we did a lot of
remote uh area work with Aboriginal
peoples and Outback things like that and
same you know in Alaska in Four Corners
a lot of work with Native and Indigenous
people that's why I know some so many of
these tidbits about sarcardia and some
of the the state names so that's kind of
an aside if we have time or if we want
to talk about that I just put in the end
like I said it didn't I needed two extra
pages for the booklet
and I think that might be it yep that's
it
can't hear but yeah I see I see waving
yeah
so I mean I guess do I do I do you want
me to take the presentation down or just
look at the comic or what
um
oh you want to stop the sharing okay
no no I didn't know if people want to
see the comic more or they obviously I
sent it around so yeah
um so stop
great
questions
um I I'd be curious
um
what
um kind of their experience as a rural
position and maybe as a as a black woman
with your all this experience
um
what I know of Rural Oregon is different
yeah
so
um what kind of Medical Practice do you
do out there and what
is your experience so overwhelmingly I
haven't done it in a while but um
um emergency medicine so I was a bit of
a I've always been kind of a bit of
hybrid so I started in surgery flipped
to emergency medicine and then when I
went to Aussie and did Rural and remote
medicine which is actually a fellowship
I did oral surgery so I kind of did
surgery again but um
um
my time in Oregon was emergency medicine
and I went all over like Astoria to John
dayda everywhere in between
um and
it's interesting you know we all I think
you know the microaggressions happen
and I think I put a little bit of that
comic when they don't know you're a
doctor so when I'm just Trucking around
pumping my gas or whatever you know you
get all of the slights but once they
figure out you're a doctor well then
they treat you different kind of thing
so so that's I think largely what I
experienced and I would say in a way I
have to remember my own privilege
because at least
I got the recompense like people knew I
was a doctor and kind of would be on
their best behavior like when you're not
or people don't know you're a doctor
that can escalate badly so I can tell
you like without going into a rural
place when I first came to Oregon
and went to the car dealer nobody spoke
to me
I remember that vividly
um and they they helped all sorts of
white couples and all sorts of people
all around me but they left me stand in
that parking lot to the point that
the the original guy who saw me came up
and apologized that that I had been
ignored
and of course then they found out I was
a doctor then they were tripping all
over themselves like what did I want to
buy you know that kind of thing so I
think what happens is that when they
don't know who you are like in many ways
you see their true selves
and then you know because it instantly
changes once they realize
um so you know the thing is
what if that's at night with a police
encounter you know
um something like that like you can see
how that can get really negative really
quickly
um but I would say also there's also the
good it's not just bad it's not just bad
and and
um I've enjoyed a lot of my time going
hither and Beyond
um I would encourage people to do so
because I think you need to get out of
an ivory Tower so the way the rest of
the world lives to realize just how
skewed it is in a place like this
um
and realize you know the lack of
resource the real struggle the barriers
that people face to Medical Care and and
Beyond to information even
so so yes I think it's important I think
it's important part of your learning and
growth
but
um but I think
the
treatment or I could say mistreatment is
real
and it would it you know I'm absolutely
sure I have a very different experience
than say a white male colleague and in
fact I've had many many of these years
white male colleagues
who wanted to see it like they would go
to a bank with me
and like when we walk up to the window
like see how I got treated versus when
we walk up to the window see how he got
treated like they wanted to see it and I
think that's what's so important I think
for so many to go out there because you
get to see that you know in a place like
this and everything's all cushy and nice
and it's Multicultural and people are
kind of you know educated and savoir
fair and engaged
you go to some of these other places and
you you
very rudely awakened I think and I think
you need to see that I think because
it's very humbling and I think it's an
important tears perspective in your
worldview
so hopefully that answers
so layout no no um just on the bottom
here
you want me to just ask it yeah sure
so I did thanks for your presentation is
really great um do you have some
suggestions for us to improve
interactions with different populations
and avoid as you know microaggressions
um it's a big question but I just
wondering if you had some ideas that you
think might be helpful
um and I'm looking at you know we can't
change history but we can make things
better
and oh and did you know that one of the
Harvard dorms that was like owned was uh
was had a had a little statue of a slave
owner
that was just like in the dorms and the
students like defaced it so
yeah so it's it's um
all of the ancient eight which are older
than America they were all built by
slaves okay they all have their slave
history yeah Brown was was the one that
kind of went out in front and put the
apology out there and put up plaques by
The English Department where it used to
be the pole and all the obviously slowly
followed um Harvard and Yale have been
last I have to admit because Yale had
Calhoun the one of their eating holes
and he was just such a racist freak it
was unbelievable and like how something
how that was named for him is just
unreal but
um so yes I am aware and and I think
these things are important I think
symbolism is important you know and I
put that in my comic you know
the general is about to be replaced by
The General
meaning get Andrew Jackson Off the 20
bill it cannot happen soon enough you
know this is a man who was the architect
of the Trail of Tears and we
immortalized him we have you know his
statue at the White House
um so Harriet Tubman can't get on there
soon enough
um it's supposed to happen like
Christmas but you know those sorts of
symbolisms are important the Maya
Angelou quarter is important so I think
I think the best that you know so many
people can do is not just give it lip
service like
own it like you know say like this is
stolen land you know I I remember I was
at REI recently and
um they have hacks now like I think it
says something like it doesn't say this
is stolen land but or this is indigenous
land
like you know like just the whole of the
place and they have a map of the U.S and
just saying this is indigenous land like
we need just like oh it's just you needs
to make a land acknowledgment Oregon
state has
uh U.S fish and wildlife has you know
like just talk about I think that's the
big thing is showing that you're aware I
think that for me that's that you know
that I'm not talking to yet another
clueless Whitey you know that I think is
is a huge
uh step because
legitimately
you don't see what we do because you
don't get treated like we do I mean
that's legitimate like it's not that
you're clueless or that you're mean or
like you know like you have a whole
different perspective that's real
and so like I think the people that go
out of their way to kind of learn like
okay like the the heavens open for me
like the society was built for me
there's all these people that it wasn't
built for
you know
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men are created equal
you know that's back when slaves weren't
even people and when we were people we
were three physical one so you know I
mean like those sorts of things like own
it like it's in our Constitution State
and National
um start making statements like that
um
to show that you're looking at this you
know like the language that we speak you
know why worship versus whitewashing
versus blackballing
like you know these are actual in the
words that we speak and so when somebody
like me you know says it's not me as the
system
I used to get a whole lot of eye rolling
like we'll have your three-time black
Ivy like what the hell's wrong with you
it's not the system you're fine you're
doing well in the system
and then you say a word like
blackwelling
that's the system
so you know that's what that's kind of
what you know and it was interesting our
former First Lady Michelle Obama I
remember when she was just becoming
first lady and she let that slip and
talked about how she wasn't proud of
some of that original history of America
because all of the found all of the
signers of the Declaration of
Independence they all owned owned slaves
except for John Adams
all of them you know and we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal while you're owning
people
you know and she called that out
and she was Savaged for it I remember
that vividly
so that's kind of what I'm saying is
that acknowledge that that is real these
are facts people
this isn't propaganda and stuff that I'm
making up
like you know
those black exclusion laws are on the
books
you know those maps are there for all of
us to see where are the trees where are
the emitters where are the white people
where are the black people it's all
right there it's right in front of your
face so I think to me I think owning it
and a knowledge and because that's how
you begin like you know it's the whole
recognition is the first symptom cure
that's the way I see it
so hopefully I've answered your question
what what
about how medicine has practiced
differently in other countries do it
and culture
yeah
um so it I think it varies I mean
frankly you know one of the things that
I always said you know because I've done
a lot of Public Health work
um
and
always done work with um Native American
tribes like kind of essentially
underserved people and
you can go to Four Corners you can also
go to northeast Portland like you don't
have to really travel or go anywhere to
find underserved populations and so I
think
some of the differences in cultures and
health systems that you're talking about
also exist
like literally within the city
so
um so like for example if you go to
Southeast Portland the Mercado and you
hear Russian
and five ancient languages in Spanish
and all of that you can get into all
sorts of differences and cultures and
Health Systems
you can do that just by going down 205.
so yes there are some but there's kind
of certain Universal truths I think you
know
when you have like like Australia New
Zealand that have the same history of
you know colonizer versus native and
that whole dynamic of light Supremacy
you kind of get a lot of the sameness
that you would get in the United States
um now they do have they fund their
health differently so that's I think a
key key metric to know is that the US is
all by itself the way we fund health
care or don't
um is very different than the rest of
the globe
and so seeing that difference I think is
important as an American doctor because
it is quite glaring it's quite shocking
and you know the beauty of America the
thing that we focus on is that it has no
ceiling but I think what we're seeing
right now
is also noting that it has a floor and
the way those other countries fund their
Health and Social systems creates a
floor that's very different than what we
see here in the U.S
um so those countries do not have the
massive homelessness problem that's
plaguing the entire West Coast in the
entire country you know there's there's
that disconnect is something I'll never
get used to because
we have less than five percent of the
world's population but over 50 of the
world's wealth and we have a mess like
that going on with people like in the
street whereas countries that have are
much more modest
seem to have a much better handle on
these kinds of things so I think there's
much to be learned by that but I think
some of the culture it's it's strikingly
similar like when you see a marginalized
disenfranchised
subset within a culture like you start
to see the same things you start to see
the alcoholism you start to see
the the same health health impacts you
know the language changes but the
struggle doesn't
yeah
so that is a medicine wheel
so um and I purposely chose that because
of my um
of my work with Native American people
so uh so it was a symbol of Native
American people of say North America
essentially
um and so the it's endless what it
actually means but it's always four
four parts four colors and you know
everything from north south east west
earth wind fire water you know and the
four Spirits the four directions so it
really it's about the wheel and the
balance and that the the recognition
that it's always spinning like while
you're focusing on one thing there's
always something else in the balance
that's not getting folks so you got to
spin the wheel and bring it back into
balance and so and and it's it's a
completely different and also it's about
Circle of Life Life Death birth
uh and it's what I the reason I love it
is that it's completely different from
the Western construct which is linear
like the for for most native peoples
worldwide one of the archetypal native
people is that they see the wheel
and so some of the things that were so
damaging to them like forcing the
children into boarding schools
like that destroyed their future because
the old people couldn't connect with the
young people and complete the wheel
so that's why that was so destroying to
entire cultures and that happened all
over the world
and so I think that that's why I embrace
it because it really it talks about a
different way of thinking a different
way of looking at the world sort of like
what we hopefully I've conveyed with Dr
invisible is like what do you see
because they clearly see something very
different
than what we do
so so
oh sorry it's an out yeah yes
well and also I didn't know if how much
discussion or how much you wanted me to
drone on at you or whatever
what do you plan to do with it
well that you know the now what is is
why I do things like this why I've
printed it why I'm getting other
eyeballs on it because you know in the
perfect world like I just did this
myself you know again with my own
printer my own stapler really kind of
you know like we bought some some paper
at Office Depot so it is it is a
homemade job
I would like to for it to be kind of
more professional I would like to kind
of get grants and really flesh out the
story because I made it four pages
because that's what I could afford and
that's what we're doing and we had a
project at a deadline but I would like
to you know in the perfect world to kind
of Flesh it out and make it like a
little graphic novel or Excel more of a
more of a story and get deeply more into
some of these issues that people raise
because many people read it and they're
like we want more can you talk about
this weathering effect or can you talk
about like you know what it was that you
went overseas and did you know there's
so many aspects that that I could do but
I not in four pages so the
the hope is you know like maybe finding
I know that there are some kind of
graphic and narrative narrative medicine
folks even within OHSU
um but how you get grants and how you
um get this funded so that you know
because all of this is very expensive as
you might imagine to pay the illustrator
to make copies all this and having the
time
um
I would love to kind of get some kind of
Grants to allow me to build this more
um and if that means kind of being
somewhere in the Academia space and like
giving lectures and then while you're
doing grants and like slowly creating
because I think uh academic space is
best suited for something like this and
so far the people that have worked with
like I said the comics they are in
um Portland State and PCC they're in
academic settings so so yes um still
learning about where those grants exist
and how and all of that but you know
that's that's part of why I did what I
did to kind of you know be like a
two-year-old be like look you know I
want to do this and because people
understand that a little bit better than
me trying to describe it
okay
thank you very much
[Music]
again yeah thank you thank you for
having me
thank you
thank you
all right thank you